as is Sanjar it was born in Turkey
in a small town called sabor
in 1946 same year as the previous
speaker he moved to United States after
having been a medical doctor in Turkey
he went to United States and got his PhD
at the University of Texas in Dallas and
he's now sir agree I am Kiran professor
of biochemistry and biophysics at
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
welcome to the stage professor Sir John
thank you very much I'm truly honored to
be here and I'm grateful to the Nobel
Prize in Chemistry selection committee
for for recognizing our work on on
mechanism of DNA repair by Fotolia and
my nuclear excision repair system which
Allah present here I think my
presentation is much longer than the
first two and I do want to make a point
because I don't want to get into Russia
in the end it is an important point of
doctor
then they'll mention yesterday that
science research is not done in vacuum
we all built on researcher research done
by our predecessors as as well as our
our contemporaries who have contributed
in significant ways to to do our own
research that that to to my personal
research that I will present here but I
will present data on photolysis
an excision repair these are two DNA
repair systems and I will also present
data on circadian clock which would
connect these two repair systems but I
really want to emphasize the
contribution of many scientists in all
these areas that have been instrumental
in accomplishing what we have and I just
did not want to leave it to the very end
so that it's mentioned in a hurry and
without proper neck recognition so I am
grateful to all these colleagues over
the years have contributed the necessary
both intellectual background and
technology and frequently regions that
that has enabled us to carry our own
research with that said then I will
present you our work in this repair
field
I will talk about to repair systems
fotolia's and nuclear taxation repairs
and and this to repair system repair DNA
damage by ultraviolet light ultraviolet
light acts on the ultraviolet light
component of sunlight actually acts on
to Jason diamonds in DNA and conversion
to time and dimer or cyclobutane
primitive dimer which is metagenic
carcinogenic and lethal to the organism
and and this damage is repaired in any
collide by an enzyme called fotolia's
and in nikola and humans by an atom
system called nuclear texas repair
system as shown and shown here i will
conclude my talk about how our research
unfertilized led to the discovery of an
essential clock protein called
cryptochrome that linked these two
research subject minim fertilized and
nuclear technician repair to to one
another and therefore completed the
circle fertilize is a what you may call
on a photon powered nanomachine nano is
popular now everything is nano and
fotolia's is a nanomachine that use
photon to repair time in dimer that is
induced by ultraviolet light fotolia's
was discovered by my mentor stand rupert
in 1958 and the discovery photolysis
it is considered the landmark discovery
that stablished the any repair as
scientific research topic decades before
discovery of fertilized by dr. rupert it
was none of that
ultraviolet can killed bacterial cells
like shown here depending on the dose
with great efficiency and and and that's
what that was
repeated many times but in 1949 arm
Turner from Brandeis made the
interesting observation that if bacteria
killed by ultraviolet light were exposed
to two blue light miraculously they were
brought back from the dead and and that
was a miraculous fine and of course are
and he had no explanation for it and
then dr. Rupert took this issue and
analyzed it and what he did was first he
demonstrated that ultraviolet to light
kill cells by damaging DNA and that the
arm there was in hands-on that repairs
the DNA damage in a light dependent
manner and that was the reason for
resurrecting light as resurrecting dead
bacteria from life that was there was no
miracle there was no metaphysics in it
it was simple physics and and the
reaction mechanism that dr. Cooper came
up with is summarized here
ultraviolet converts to adjacent time is
to time and dimer and there is an enzyme
called fertilised which years
is blue light energy to break these
abnormal bounce bounce and convert the
timing dimer to tune normal basis and
therefore repair DNA and eliminate the
harmful effect of ultraviolet light
now while this this was a satisfactory
explanation it raised the physical
problem fertilize is in enzyme is
protein proteins do not absorb a blue
light and and therefore for the next two
decades Rupert and many other scientists
try to identify the blue light absorbing
component in photo light and they were
unsuccessful because dr. Evert had
determined that an e coli cell contains
only about ten to twenty molecules of
enzyme and this proved impossible to
purify so in 1974 when i joined dr.
ripples lab the gene Conan had just been
developed at Stanford and as a fresh
graduate student I thought I could do
anything I wanted and I proposed to dr.
Rupert to clone the fertilizing and
overproduce it and purify it and he said
go ahead and I cook and I cloned it I I
cloned the gene oh and this is the
plasmid with the fertilized gene on it
and in in the subsequent years at the
University of North Carolina my
colleagues and I purified this
fertilized protein in gram quantities
and while we purified it we found that
it has a bright blue color and right
there
that fine then without any analytical
chemistry answered the question of what
was it in fertilized that absorb light
and and catalyze the action
it had the blue color meaning it absorbs
light nevertheless we had to identify
what the material was that that absorb
blue color and we carried out analytical
chemistry analysis on the enzyme and to
our surprise we found that it contained
not one but two cofactors one flavin
adenine dinucleotide and the other
folate and that the enzyme actually
could exhibit colors ranging from purple
all the way to to orange depending on
the various redox status of the flavin
cofactor in any event the enzyme
contains two cofactors one is fall it
and one is the flavin and our next task
was done to determine the function of
these two cofactors by caring for the
chemical experiment we found that folate
actually acts as a solar panel it
absorbs light and just like solar panel
it transfers the energy to the flavin
and the flavin is the catalyst that
carriers the cattle catalytic reaction
to submit the primitive primitive dimer
to provide structural basis for fault
for this photochemical data we
collaborated with Hans Dyson hopper to
obtain a crystallized fertilize and
obtain a three-dimensional structure
which is shown here in ribbon diagram
and surface chart
representation and like I said for it is
really um a solar receptor sits on the
roof of the protein gathers blue light
energy and transfer the energy to the
flavin in the core of the protein to
carry out catalysis with with this
general structure than the mechanism for
fotolia's was developed as shown here
the enzyme binds to that DNA containing
of thymine dimer because Lyman dimer
cause a normal structure in the backbone
and it pulls the thymine dimer from
within the helix into Van der Waals
contact with the flavin and it makes a
very stable complex nothing happens on
until a blue light photon is absorbed by
the folate which transfers the
excitation energy to flavin and the
flavin repels the cyclobutane dimer or
thymine dimer by a cyclic redox reaction
the dimer is repaired and the enzyme
dissociate from DNA and goes on to
search for new damaged site and and to
reinitiate the cycle over the past 10
years in collaboration with a dumping
zone from Ohio State University we have
determined the microscopic rate reaction
for every single step in catalysis from
absorbing light energy transfer and
various types of electron transfer
our bond cleavage bond formation and
back electron transfer to make long
story short we have the rate constant at
Pico second resolution in real time for
the catalytic reaction on and the entire
catalytic cycle takes about 1.2
nanosecond fertilizing in addition to
and its intrinsic value is actually
contributed the other major repair
mechanism that that's fun in many
organism and that is nucleotide excision
repair which is the other topic of my
research in the early days of work on on
photolysis they did the way the
experiment was done cells would be
responded in in buffer and and they
would be irradiated with ultraviolet
light and and half the sample would be
captain dark and the other would be
exposed to blue light and then they were
be analyzed for thymine dimer content of
course the one exposed to blue light
thymine dimers would disappear the one
that was in dark timing Dahmer's
repaired in the genome however if a
small change was made in that design if
the buffer contains glucose it was found
that even the ones that were kept in
dark
losted dimers from the genome but there
was a difference between the that loss
and the loss that was caused by Fotolia
when the cells were captain dark in the
presence of glucose even though the
dimers were lost from the genomes they
were within the cells they will come
from the genome but they were in the
cytosol and that led to the concept of
nucleotide excision repair by how hard
Flanders at Yale and on Seth law at
Oakridge National
Nitori and that that will is the the
next topic that I'll be talking about
so after this initial discovery by Seth
line and heart Flanders research was
done in many labs from from 9 1964 till
1982 and the basic conclusion from this
studies are summarized here
timing diamonds are removed from the
genome both Ecoline humans and exercise
diamond Demers were found to be in
oligonucleotide four to six nucleotides
in ninth and it was also found that this
repair reaction is genetically
controlled by the VR genes in e.coli UV
are a b and c and expedience in humans
and experience there were seven of them
XB a through x PG and that the basic
reaction mechanism is what we call
underneath lays eggs on a place coupled
with repair synthesis but importantly
the excise dimers remained in the cell
as opposed to photo reactivation so so
this was the de vere in 1982 and 1987
after my my initial work on fertilizing
in dr. rupert lab i I joined the in roof
lab at Keele University to study the
coli nuclear technician repair and for
that I cloned the regions that were
implicated in excision repair give er a
EVR be any VRC nothing was known about
about these genes and what what they did
I developed a maxi cell method for
specifically radio label and plasmid
encoded gene and identified the district
proteins as hundred
80 85 and 70 kilo Dalton proteins and
then purify them in milligram quantities
as shown here in Kumasi blue stain gel
and ask the question how do these
proteins carry the repair reaction and
what I found was was this and this was
different from the classic and the
nucleus eggs and place reaction
mechanism in that the three proteins
acting together made incisions at
precise site 7 nucleotides 5 prompted
damage and 3 nucleotides 3 prompted
damage to release an olive a nucleotide
of twelve nucleotides and then a gap was
filled and and and and ligated and
heavenly the basic mechanism is
established with these three proteins
than later on at the University of North
Carolina my my colleagues and I studied
the individual function of these
proteins and we established this
reaction mechanism give er a recognized
damage reclusive ER be promoting a very
stable give er be damaged DNA complex
which then recruits GV RC has the tunic
plays active site makes the dual
incision and then uvr sees this
displaced by by helices a VAR b by
primers and the cap is still delegated
well this purpose was going on phil
hannah wat at stanford published paper
shown that both in e.coli and any humans
on
transcription strongly stimulated repair
and and he and others suggested that the
reason for this was because the rate
limiting step in repair is on the damage
recognition step and and and the
explanation was that our nem'ro's
thought that the damage site cannot pass
the damage and and it constitute a large
target and as a consequence it is a good
target for damage recognition and that's
how it facilitates repair so we tested
this model and in the file system
meaning the EVR ABC and RNA polymerase
with subject content timing Dahmer we
found that in contrast to them to that
model stalled RNA polymerase did not
stimulate repair but actually inhibited
and therefore we proposed that there
must be a protein that removes told RNA
polymerase and on top that recruits the
repair protein to accelerate the repair
rate and we proceeded to purify this
protein using biochemical assay and the
real results are shown here we purified
this protein we call the transcription
repair coupling factor turned out that
to be a gene that had been identified
decades ago and with with regard to
mutagenesis study by Evelyn Witkin and
was then MFD in an event MFD or
transcription repair coupling factor
indeed recognized all the RNA polymerase
at damage tried displaced sit and while
a concomitant recruiting EVR a to
accelerate to repair rate so i at this
point we figured that we had completed
the description of prokaryotic repair
though in science never
anything completely complete are but we
moved on to study human excision repair
and that is what I will present you and
in the next few is slide in Hindman
excision repair as I mentioned it was
funded like an e : human excision repair
basically preceded by the same mechanism
meaning arm a five-prime endonuclease
recognizing damage to make incision and
then in exonuclease removes the damage
in four to six nuclear lung other
Gummer's concomitant with repair since
the filling the gap so this was the
current state of knowledge one when we
started working on nuclear excision
repair in him as I would also point out
that in 1968
James Cleaver had found that him is
defective in nuclear technician repair
or or rather patients with very large
sensitiveness this is called xeroderma
pigmentosum
were defective in nucleotide excision
repair and moreover that there were
seven genes that were responsible for
this disease meaning mutation in any of
these genes could cause defect in
nuclear technician repair and therefore
xeroderma pigmentosum
i am and i will show you a picture of a
patient with xeroderma pigmentosum
some colleagues found the picture very
disturbing and they advised me not to
short more than five seconds and and
that's what i will do it is it is very a
severe disease patients have five
thousand fold increase in
sunlight in this skin cancer and I will
not keep it more than five seconds so
using our our expertise and working with
the coli excision repair we went on to
characterized human excision repair
first up from from the very beginning we
found that the human excision repair
just like e.coli excision repair is also
carried out by dual incision but beyond
that it was very different to begin with
and in Hindman excision repair not just
three proteins but in fact 16 proteins
and sixth repair factors are shown here
were absolutely essential for making the
dual incision and furthermore these
proteins are evolutionary not related to
the excision repair proteins involved in
in prokaryotic repair secondly even
though in principle both ecoli
and humans carry out the excision repair
by during season that's where the
similarity stops the dual incision
mechanisms are quite different and
whereas in humans that incision is 70
clutters away from the damaged in humans
is 20 to 22 nucleotide fire prompted
damage and five nuclear die three
prompted to the thymine dimer as a
consequence humans removed thymine
dimers in the form of a 30 nucleotide
long oligomers the the difference does
not stop here the actual mechanism also
the recognized recognition process in
processing is quite different
the damage is recognized by
this factory xprp exbc which recruit the
HDF nature as the hillock as a TPS on
one day the helix and down the crews the
turn necklaces xbg and xpf which makes
the five prime three prime incision and
then the repair is completed by
polymerase and and i am and like this
now in all these some studies or over
deals both us and other groups work on
human nucleotide excision repair law if
this was confirmed by many other groups
that chemists did excise a thirteen
declare a long oligomers but really a
serious issue remained and that was the
many studies prior at publish that
humans excised the oliver in four to six
nucleotide long fragments and here all
these experiments were done in vitro and
we with identify a 30 nucleotides long
fragment in the emitter experiment and
therefore there was a discrepancy
between in vitro and in vivo data and it
took us 21 years to to resolve this
discrepancy and the key was to we found
that the excise all ago the size
oligonucleotide the 30 mer is in a very
tight complex with this repair factor
called KF 2h once we found that then we
said we can omit precipitated and
measure the actual size when we did it
indeed turned out to be in vivo also 30
nucleotide and that discrepancy was
because in the other in vivo experiments
that dial ago was delayed in any event
in me what the oligonucleotide is is
also the
Nicoletta the ninth but this also
provides us the means of generating a
repair map for the entire human genome
as shown here we Aradia cells with TV
photoproduct
are made and the dual incision released
or a third teamer and thus in a complex
with tf2h and we are immunoprecipitate
tf2h to isolate both TF tation and the
oligonucleotide with it then extract the
oligonucleotide and sequence it by
next-generation sequencing to generate
sequences from the entire genome in a
typical experiment we get 20 million
sequences then we blast these 20 million
articles against the human genome to
generate an entire map or for the repair
map for the human genome and this is a
an entire map for the human repair
genome for a male individual of 21 22
plus X plus y chromosome the black
tracks showed a transcription of tracks
and the green are repaired tracks for
two types of photo products of course
this is a screenshot of the entire
genome and it cannot really tell much
much detail of what's going on I will
concentrate on one specific chromosome
17 there's an important chromosome it
contains of the p53 gene which is
mutated in about half of human cancer
and that that will give a better idea of
kind of kind of information one can get
from from the human genome repair map
this is chromosome 17 is 83
megabase and here we've shown the
transcription of +1 and - friend and the
excision repair we called exotic
excision repair map for for the whole
genome and it is really a map in the
true sense of the word in the geographic
sense meaning it has mountain
it has valleys and it has canyons
meaning high repair low repair and no
repair at all but importantly we can ask
question at for any particular position
nucleotide or dinucleotide how that
place is repaired and and and just to
give you an example of for now this is
the location of p53 and the location of
a pivot rip dilated which is highly
mutated in skin cancers so at mega base
that's where it is at killer base
resolution this is the p53 the
transcript map and this is the p53
repair map the arm specific um hot spot
for UV induced occur cancer is this
dinucleotide and here our repair map
shows how this dinucleotide this hot
spot is repaired by cuttin 20 nucleotide
5 prime and for for nucleotide 3
promptitude damage of course this much
more information can be gathered from
this kind of map for for UV damage most
importantly this method nuclear
technician repair also repairs of the
damage caused by very important
anti-cancer drugs cisplatin
currently we are generating a repair map
for cisplatin and this DNA damage and we
hope that that might might have some
implication for for cancer treatment to
summarize then nuclear technician repair
is initiated by during incision botany :
humans excision genetically controlled
by UV are in E coli experienced in
humans an excision is not by
endonuclease ex-analyst it is by during
scission removing 12th nuclear test in
e.coli 13 in humans as shown here and
follow an excision the repair job is
filled and ligated and by capturing the
excels a legume er we have managed to
generate a repair map or the entire
human genome I would like to close my my
my presentation with a few word about
cryptochrome and how the work
unfertilized led to discovery of
cryptochrome now if you feel if if you
noticed in discussion fertilize and
recruit excision repair I refer to both
ecoli and human nuclear taxi juniper but
when I discussed fertilized I mentioned
only ecoli fertilized because humans do
not have fertilize this this is a fact
now but for about 25 years after
discovery of fertilized it was not
affect it was a very controversial
subject a number of investigative
reporting photo lights and others saying
no so in 1993 we decided to resolve this
issue and we carried out an extensive
study unfertilized in humans and we
published a paper categorically stand
stating humans do not have fertilized
and it didn't take long for the human
genome project to release their first
draft and saying that humans do have a
fertilized homo log and so we of course
were concerned that we made a major
mistake and decided to work on the soma
log while doing that we end up
discovering a second home Ola oh so then
we have not one but two or more logs and
we decided to investigate but these
proteins - as you see here at the
primary sequence level they are very
similar to fertilize and importantly
even at 3d structure level they are very
similar fertilized so we went on to
purify them and test them for fertiliser
activity and we found none and at that
point we named them cryptochrome in
analogy to a blue light photoreceptors
of Baudette named implants and I'll try
to see what what they do so there have
high-quality to fertilize they are
similar to fertilize they have no
fertilized activity they're probably
blue light photoreceptors and this is
what happened after these findings this
finding was made in the spring of 1996
and at the end of spring in May I made
my annual pilgrimage to Turkey to visit
my family and thinking about what we
were going to do with those findings and
on my return trip I read the flight
magazine talkin about jet lag and jet
lag and circadian clock
and how this could be cured by blue
light and I came back to the lab and I
said cryptochromes our circadian clock
proteins and we wrote the paper and at
the end of August and it was published
in November but saying is easy proven
takes time it took us another two years
to prove that these were circadian clock
proteins but but just to to say a few
words about kidding clock is
circadian clock is just like the clocks
that we are familiar with there are
mechanical clock electronic clock they
are based on either mechanic's
principles or electronic principle and
the circadian clock has some kind of
design except here the components are
molecules and and their function is to
keep time of day to tell us well what
time day it is and that's what the
circadian clock does our circadian clock
is an innate timekeeping mechanism
molecular mechanism that maintains data
ethnicity and biochemical physiological
and behavioral functions and this is
independent of external stimuli so with
with this background and to test whether
the cryptochromes
were circadian clock proteins or not we
generated mice with nacos in
cryptochrome on cryptochrome tear and
both cryptochrome on cryptochrome - and
analyze them for behavior this is called
actogram you really don't need to know
about the detail of it with recording
the activity profile of mice that were
kept for 28 hours for for the experiment
for the first week they were on the
light dark cycle the the black traces
indicate act
and the white traces or what regions
show rest period and mice are nocturnal
they run during the day and they rest
earn during the night they rest during
the day and this shameful welt up for
cryptochrome one mitten cryptochrome two
mitten and double mutant when they are
on the light-dark cycle however when you
when you put their animals on the dark
dark condition meaning no external input
then you see the difference both
cryptochrome month and cryptochrome -
without having to really know much about
it the behavior is quite different but
most importantly the double knockout
mutant has no circadian clock anymore so
so distant established that these
proteins are essential for circadian
clock and during while this was working
going on in the period of 1996 to 2000
there was a great deal of progress in
the circadian field that led to the
establishment of four genes cryptochrome
period clock and beam l1 as essential
for controlling the circadian clock in
humans and this was the model that was
developed Clarke BML are transcription
factors activate transcription of
cryptic Roman period and this proteins
come back and inhibit their own
transcription result in and rise in full
and cryptochrome up period levels with
periodicity of 24 hours in addition this
proteins meaning this core clock disk or
clock proteins these four proteins act
on in any given tissue on 30% of other
genes to confer this cyclic expression
pattern with what
daily periodicity and therefore control
the biological function with daily
periodicity and among this we fund the
excision repair protein XPA was also
controlled by the circadian clock and
therefore we ask the question whether
the whole nucleotide excision repair is
controlled by circadian clock this is
the circadian clock and this is the
nucleotide excision repair and so we're
asking question if this clock controls
this nuclear excision repair with daily
periodicity and the answer is yes in
this panel you show the expression
pattern of XP a protein which is
essential for excision repair over the
course of day it's low in at 9:00 a.m.
it goes up reaching a maximum at 5:00
p.m. and a den start going down to a
minimum at 5:00 a.m. that done led to
the prediction that mice would be more
sensitive to UV light when exposed to at
5:00 a.m. when repair is low compared to
5:00 p.m.
mine repair is high and we proceeded to
do that irradiated two groups of mice
with ultraviolet light one group at 5:00
p.m. when repairs hi one group at 5:00
a.m. when repair is law and as you see
the 5 a.m. group at the irradiated low
repair period low repair time at 4 to 5
fold increased and invasive skin
carcinoma compared to the 5 p.m. repair
group so currently we are trying to find
out or establish whether this
periodicity also happens in humans
and whether that can be used in
preventing arm making Public Health
recommendations prevents it skin cancer
and equally important since this repair
system works on cisplatin induce DNA
damage for forecast treatment whether
this periodicity could be used to
improve cisplatin treatment of cancers
to summarize to conclude this is really
summary of my 40 years of fork on
photolysis 35 30 35 years of work on
excision repair in e.coli in humans and
over the last 20 years we have found
that the the photo lasts like
cryptochrome links these two repair
pathways that we have worked I have
worked all my career this doesn't really
do justice to to my colleagues
the acknowledgement they are as a large
number people have contributed to to
this work and they will be properly
acknowledged in the noble proceedings
and I have been very fortunate to have
outstanding mentors
especially Stan Rupert who has been my
role model and who is the person who
discovered DNA repair and introduced me
to the NFL field and being a Turk I
would also wish to agonal acknowledge
muzaffer ox or my internal medicine
professor who encouraged me to go to
United State and and do science and my
other mentors roopd Anoop and Paul Hart
plan
my collaborators among them paul modrich
and others and as I said science is not
done in vacuum
we have benefited greatly from
colleagues who simultaneously carried
similar work unfertilized on circadian
clock and on occasion repair and I'm
grateful to all of them as well and I
thank you very much for your patient
thank you very much I think we can all
sleep well it's nice knowing that our
molecules do the job for us
I would all like to welcome all three
laureates up to the stage yes